recount there's a recount oh come on
it's over just concede newport won by 21
votes that's well within the margin for
a recount
please don't do this i really want to
get out of here how about this
why don't i make you guys a deal okay
there's no deal in the world that we
would ever possibly give you joe biden's
home phone number
now hang on that's interesting i know
you're not thinking clearly mr
commissioner
the recount has to start immediately
it's the law now i'm not leaving until
you make the call
he's ride miss barkley it'll start right
away keep your phones on
terrance i just want to go
home
chris right hi i'm jen hello
you know there are 30 bedrooms in this
house
bobby's in one there's a dead guy in
another the rest are free
what do you say oh
that is very flattering but you're the
opposition campaign manager
i i couldn't do that to leslie oh for
god's sake chris
this campaign is over my job is done and
so is yours it's just sex
i'm very good at it okay great
let's do it okay having a good all day
honey
so what's ben's next move for you oh oh
i'm not gonna tell you that oh let me
guess
um you're gonna attack me you're gonna
go on that perm show again
so you can tell everyone that that ramp
idea was yours it's
perd first of all and no maybe no
that's not a terrible idea you know
actually it is kind of terrible because
if you go on the air and tell everybody
that i stole your idea which i did
everyone's gonna think you're a sore
loser a goody goody
cause you know what people don't care
about they don't care about
whose idea was first they care about
whose idea
was best well let's say that that was
our plan which it isn't okay
what would you do instead oh leslie
i really shouldn't give you campaign
advice right yeah what the hell
if you love chess which i do but you
don't have anybody to play against which
i don't
and sometimes you just gotta play
yourself you could attack the newport
plan for costing too much money
no but that would backfire because then
we would just say you can never spend
too much on seniors
of course you need to beat our idea come
up with something better
i don't know maybe a free shuttle
service for seniors
all right that could work wow waffles
and a cappuccino
gracias marta jj's doesn't have a
cappuccino maker no it does now
i bought him one of course you did
whoa what was that that was huge let's
talk shop ooh shop talk
one of my five favorite types of talk
along with pillow girl real and ted
why are you wearing a poncho oh because
every surface area in your house is
sticky
last time i was here i found it melted
crayon on my blazer
okay i have a photo op with grizzle
tomorrow
between now and then we have a ton of
stuff scheduled looks like we're gonna
have to skip
the pie baking event and ceremonial
squash toss
oh really we have to skip that i love
watching those squashes fly through the
air
i kind of like the way they land me too
okay excuse me but i have to get back to
a city
where things happen okay this campaign
is about to start in earnest
things are about to get real intense you
ready oh
yeah i already made my pump up mix you
know there's a surprising amount of pat
benatar
nice i was talking to leslie me leslie
yeah well i was an actual candidate so i
think i can handle being a candidate's
wife
i know all the issues inside and out see
that's the problem
if you were just a ding-dong i would
just slap a flag pin on you pour some
valium down your throat yeah everything
would be fine
the smarties that freak people out i
think you're underestimating the voters
i don't think that is possible being the
wife of
is a minefield right ben you know
what do you think of it like um sex
freshman year of college
i just kind of want to get through it as
fast as possible without embarrassing
yourself
i'm using that as an analogy to help you
out because i'm assuming you're a late
bloomer
not me i crushed it from day one oh
stephen be careful
pancho oh damn it didn't get a chance to
say goodbye to chris
oh he's just right over there
ah he seems really busy anyway would you
tell him i said goodbye great thank you
sorry we didn't get a chance to meet i'm
ann that doesn't matter i'm leaving
jen what are you doing here you idiots
want to answer my calls and what i have
to tell you cannot wait
what's that horrible sound children oh
your life is gross my life is amazing
jen thank you so much for coming but we
have to go i have never been late for an
event that requires an rsvp
you guys live in pawnee indiana where do
you have to go putting up a new
scarecrow
could you please just get to the point
sure yeah you are a surprise surprise
whoa ooh if you guys should have corner
boothed it cause you look awful
scare off the other customers hey jen
all those kids keep you up all night
so happy with my choices okay jen yeah
um i know i i left you a message last
night but
i i i really do think you should have
checked with me before throwing me into
this i'm sorry you left me four messages
last night what they contain very
specific policy positions
i want to come out strong on education
then i'll tack heart into fiscal
responsibility
daddy i got you hey baby
wow honey you were a lot more lucid than
i was
wait were you guys drunk
that is hilarious no we oh you guys are
gonna fit in so great in washington most
of congress is drunk all the time
okay official presser is tomorrow at
nine could bail if you want but it would
be embarrassing
might derail your career might not
probably will but you never do know
though right
so just let me know what you want to do
okay well i'm just gonna go spend my
time doing exactly what i want to do
because i don't have children bye guys
your boy looks a little lost out there
oh he'll be fine
expectations are crazy low if he puts
two sentences together without crying
the press is going to say he's doing
surprisingly well and if he falls to
pieces he's gonna look sympathetic it's
a win-win
so you have any idea how long this is
gonna take apparently leslie knope
wielded her insider influence and got
councilman pilner
to save her precious department even
though it meant closing the shelter
now i'm not saying that leslie knope is
a dog murderer per se
i just think that her actions raise some
questions like for example
is she a dog murderer oh god well we
look serious
that's on the agenda just one item
jennifer you are going to announce that
bobby newport will use his personal
fortune to save the animal shelter
no no that's that's um
that is a great idea in fact i don't
know why i hadn't thought of it already
damn it damn it i swear the air in this
town is killing my brain cells
actually the water's not good for you
either you shouldn't drink the tap water
has anyone told you that yet
in exchange no more puppy killer ads for
the rest of the campaign
that's all we ask okay well what's to
stop
me from just paying for the shelter and
still running the ads because i told
councilman pilner that if you don't
agree to our terms he should cut the
park's budget
and will leak that it was leslie's
decision making her seem tough and fair
what with sacrificing her old apartment
okay
what's in it for you a safe home for the
animals a job for my friend and a full
parks budget
i wasn't born yesterday you've got to
have an angle this is a home run for us
we're going to dominate the news cycle
for a whole week
what you can have this week we'll take
the next one oh yeah
what makes you so sure because in a week
we have a debate
and your guy bobby newport is gonna have
to show up and he's gonna have to open
his mouth
and i'm gonna kick his ass she'll take
care of that
see you next week
i'm sorry if it felt like everyone piled
on we were just being honest
but if you really want to do this of
course we'll support you
thank you i'm sorry i stormed out you
know i've been thinking for weeks of
what to get you as a last day in city
council present
i finally figured it out you remember
jen barkley political consultant and
power broker
hey jen what brings you back to pawnee
ben bought one hour of my time i heard
you need some consulting
well uh i guess i mean how are you how's
your family okay i
get paid 1200 an hour do you really want
to spend any of that time talking about
my mother and her 19 year old korean
husband
well that does sound fascinating but
you're right let's talk okay get the
chair
so they recall me after all i've done
for them ridiculous but dex heart now
has another sex case of course he does
and the plan is i'm gonna run for a seat
because how do i lose to a guy like that
that's a great idea right it's a
terrible idea i knew it wait what first
of all you could lose to a guy like that
terrible people defeat great people all
of the time i should know it's terrible
people have paid me so much money at a
condo in every virgin island
now you might win you're smart ben is
smart you might win
but why would you want to because it's
my dream job
then dream bigger look you love this
town it's being run by monsters and
morons get a better job
rise above their heads effect change at
a higher level don't be the kid that
graduates high school hangs out in the
school parking lot be the woman who
moves away
climbs the ladder and then confidently
comes back and has sex with her hot old
english teacher just for kicks
is that what you did yeah mr baker sex
was pretty good thanks to me
look bonnie has done you a favor you've
outgrown them
you've got talent you've got name
recognition which means that you have a
bright
wide-open future with a thousand options
state senate federal jobs
even congress all of these are doable
for you
and you can trust me
because i don't care enough about you to
lie
uh oh oh time's up okay if you want to
keep talking you're gonna have to pay me
1200 more dollars
i just need to i swear to god if you say
one more word you will legally owe me
twelve hundred dollars and i will sue
you
let's not end it like that okay great to
see you leslie those five words are on
me
should i move this back don't answer it
you